Should we just fuck?
I feel like we're before and after pictures right now!
You're the after.
I'm after, like, Thanksgiving.
What?
I don't know. It just felt right.
So, it rained today, huh?
It did.
That was weird.
Cause I don't do well in the rain.
Like, when I left my house, I was a skinny white girl and then I turned to this when I get wet.
I've been drinking...
Yeah.
You're not serious though, right?
No!
For 9 years and now he like, doesn't-
Spring cleaning, bitch! Throw away the dusty dick and get a new, shiny one.
What's in San Francisco? It sounds lovely.
I'm writing for the Rolling Stone.
What? Like, the Stone?
Yeah.
The one Stone? I thought it was more stones!
-bit of strogonoff.
What's happening?
Are you breathing bad air?
You're not making a sound.
You're mouth is just open.
Who am I kidding?
Podcasts!
Sorry, my bad.
It's about dick, actually.
It's about finding dick.
Oh, shit! It is about dick.
You see what I'm saying?
Can I have a sip of that?
Yeah, for sure.
Cool, cool, cool,cool, cool, cool.
I do get cold sores.
Oh, I'm cool. Thanks.
Got them because my mom kissed me when I was young. She had them.
So, it was not from, like, a boy or anything.
Yeah. But, your mom was sucking, like, dirty dick.
No. No?
Maybe.
Are you alright?
I've got a cue tip. You kind of look crazy.
You want the cue tip?
Just under your eye? Maybe the little crust right here?
Yeah!
-looking crazy as fuck but still got standards.
Thank you.
You know what I mean?
Like I wasn't sure if you were homeless cause the rips in your jeans were so big.
But I was like maybe she really likes Rent the musical.
My ass is clenched. My jaw is locked. I'm stressed!
I've never had a locked jaw. Is that painful?
Oh, yes. Especially when the dick is so big. You're just like, what?
-wanna send me a picture of your feet? I can hook you up in, like, 20 minutes.
My feet?
Yeah, your feet.
I don't have the greatest feet.
Oh, maybe that's why he left?
You know, I'm gonna get some turmeric.
It's great for inflammation.
Yeah, that's what they said. That's what I need it for, cause, you know, 1 in 4.
What? 1 in 4 what?
What?
-need love no matter what.
You know what I mean? They do. They just really do. like...
I love you!
I agree, I agree.
I love you so much.
Oh, did you and Nate live together? Ya'll had pets?
No.
No?
No. I don't fucking like pets.
-scared ya, didn't I?
Ya did. You've been scaring me since you sat down here.
Who has a polaroid, ya know? It feels very "Lovely Bones".